la visita que no ha sido confirmada aún
oficialmente por eeuu dispara la tensión
en estrecho de formosa y ahora se
plantean las dudas de cómo va a
reaccionar china después de haber
encadenado amenazas durante una semana
el presidente chino xi jinping advirtió
a su homólogo joe biden de que si seguía
jugando con fuego con taiwán se quemaría
y el ministerio de defensa también ha
advertido en los últimos días de que el
ejército no se quedará con los brazos
cruzados pero si ha puesto a china ante
una situación muy delicada a la de tomar
medidas militares inéditas con
consecuencias imprevisibles o la de
dejar pasar la crisis con algún
editorial inflamado o pataletas
diplomáticas lo que sí que podemos
confirmar ya es que se ha disparado la
las acciones en las aguas de taiwán por
un lado barcos y aviones de guerra
chinos se han acercado a lo que se
conoce como la línea media que es la
frontera oficiosa entre china y taiwán
por el otro
eeuu ha enviado a cuatro barcos de
guerras entre ellos un portaaviones al
este de la isla en lo que ha calificado
como maniobras rutinarias lo que queda
claro es que ya ni siquiera las charlas
presidenciales entre sí y bardem sirven
para mantener la calma ni siquiera unos
días a pesar de que las partes las
habían definido como profundas y
sinceras